[Music]
this silent fusion of the pithless
essentialities of the evaporated life
has
however still to be taken in the other
meaning of the actuality of
conscience and in the manifestation of
its movement
conscience has to be considered as
acting
the objective moment in this
consciousness acquired above the
determination
of a universal consciousness the
knowledge that
knows itself is qua this particular self
distinct from other selves the language
in which all reciprocally acknowledge
each other as acting conscientiously
this universal identity falls apart into
the non-identity
of individual being for self each
consciousness is just as much simply
reflected out of its universality into
itself
as a result the antithesis of
individuality to other individuals
and to the universal inevitably comes on
the scene
and we have to consider this
relationship and its movement
in other words this universality and
duty
have the very opposite significance of
the specific individuality
that exempts itself from the universal
for which pure duty
is only a universality that appears on
the surface
and is turned outwards duty is only a
matter of words
and counts as a being for another
conscience which in the first instance
is only negatively directed against duty
as this given specific duty knows itself
to be free from it but
since it fills the empty duty with a
specific content from itself
it is positively aware that it as
this particular self makes the content
its pure self as an empty knowing is
something devoid of content
and determination the content which it
gives to that knowing is taken from its
own self
as this specific self is taken from
itself as a natural individuality
and in speaking of the conscientiousness
of its action
it may well be aware of its pure self
but in the purpose of its action
a purpose with an actual content it is
aware of itself
as this particular individual and is
conscious of the antithesis between
what it is for itself and what it is for
others of the antithesis of universality
or duty
and its reflection out of universality
into itself
paragraph 659 represents a
turning back to the active the
acting consciousness the one who is
trying to act
in accordance with conscience
and if there's a contrast here to what
was developed in the previous paragraph
the shape of the
beautiful soul who does not act
precisely
so as to not besmirch itself
by engaging in particularity you might
say and so
we're coming back now to looking at well
what happens when you
do in fact take some sort of stand what
happens when you
do in fact follow your conscience
does the the equilibrium
of acknowledgement in language that we
attained
up to this point does that actually
provide us with anything and the answer
in this paragraph
is is no so he begins by talking about
this silent fusion of pithless that's
heartless essentialities of the
evaporated life
has to be taken in the other meaning of
the actuality of conscience and the
manifestation
of its movement conscience has to be
considered
as acting now what does it mean to be
considered as acting
so the word here is honda right the
the verb not just to act but to comport
oneself so it's not just doing
a single thing it's a line of behavior
and we could call this an orientation
we could call this intentional action if
you like
and hegel is going to use a phrase in
two different ways
running throughout this paragraph that's
that's worth
bringing up so we've got this theme
we can call it of reflection out of
universality
into its self and he brings this up
uh midway through and at the very end so
at the very end he says that
and speaking of the conscientiousness of
its action
it may well be aware of its pure self
but in the purpose of its action a
purpose with an actual content which
we're going to get to in a bit
it is aware of itself as this particular
individual
and is conscious of the antithesis
between what it is for itself and what
it is for others
of the antithesis of universality or
duty and its
reflection out of universality into
itself its reflection
out of universality into itself is being
opposed here
to duty so something is happening the
on the side of the universal that's the
side of duty
something is happening that is a
reflection and hegel is using
the the latina term reflection
right he's not using any sort of
german term for this he also uses
a verbal form of it reflect
a little bit earlier so we should take a
look at that passage
as well he says the knowledge that knows
itself
is qua this particular self distinct
from other selves
the language in which all reciprocally
acknowledge each other is acting
conscientiously this universe
the universal identity falls apart into
the non-identity of the individual being
for itself
each consciousness is just as much
simply reflected out of its universality
into itself now in that point he does
he's not talking about universality
without any qualifier he's designer it's
it's universality right
so in the previous paragraphs we saw
that you know the
the the conscientious
individual the person who's acting in
accordance with conscience
can view themselves as acting in
accordance with the universal as in a
certain sense embodying it
and there was also this sense of
community to the point where we could
actually have like a
religious object in the community
and it was reinforced with language here
things are now breaking apart
through this reflection into itself so
so what is this reflection what what is
going on here
we should look at this as um
a sort of focusing on one's own self
in an opposition to to
others and to the universality and this
has to happen when we act
right we've seen this dynamic play
itself out many times before
in just in this this section of morality
but also earlier
whenever you act you act as a particular
person and your action never completely
coincides with the universal as a matter
of fact it may go
go against it in some cases but
if you don't act then there's you know
all this talk about obligation or duty
flicked all this talking about purpose
it's back all this talk about you know
all the other components that go into
duty morality obligation none of them
really mean anything if we don't act and
so
we're faced with this almost tragic
situation we have to act and in doing so
we go against the universal but if we
don't then we're just a beautiful soul
we don't want to be that either so let's
take a look now at this this entire
passage he says the objective moment
the gegenschtenliche moment in this
consciousness
acquired above the determine the
termination of a universal consciousness
then he goes on he says the knowledge
that knows itself is
qua this particular self distinct from
other selves we've already just brought
that up
so knowing yourself knowing willing
acting
speaking we saw earlier that these all
go together
in moral or intentional action so
knowing here is not just a pure abstract
this and
you know a knowing that has only
reference to
understanding the world it's also about
knowing
one's duties knowing one's relations to
others understanding perhaps means and
ends you know what's required
in the situation and that particularizes
or individuates a person a consciousness
from other consciousnesses right it's
distinct from other selves
and all of this you know the language um
where there's reciprocal acknowledgement
uh
universal identity falls apart into a
non-identity of being
for self so what does he mean their
non-identity of being for
self well there's different ways of
understanding being for self it can be
understood as sort of reflexivity
it can also be understood in a way that
you could you might call
sartrian although sart is really just
picking this up hegel is already talking
about this here
where there is a disunity
a disjunction within the the self itself
right the self is taking a stand on
itself not
simply in a pure harmony or unity but
but as
you know saying oh wow you know when i
here's a trivial example of it past greg
didn't shoot these videos when he should
have and now
that bastard has got me doing extra work
at this point in time
there's a disunity there right or i can
think
am i really up to engaging in this
motive
action that i've decided upon those
those uncertainties those are all just
examples i don't want you to take those
as being the paradigms
for it let's go on so he says that
um here we go
as a result the antithesis or you can
say opposition
again gegenzotz he's been using this
quite a bit
in this uh this section
gaggins thoughts not exactly the same
thing as antithesis
uh the way that sometimes gets brought
up but it does mean opposition
right uh an antithesis enters in or is
introduced
you know literally steps in uh you can
say what space is it stepping into oh we
could
figure that out later and what is the
opposition between the individual
einzelheit right the the one who is
on their own the one who is identifiable
and we might even say responsible right
who can say i
do this i choose this and
two other things two other sets of
things
no they're not things right other
individuals
uh andre and einselmann right
so this is an opposition between one
one self and others who are
in some respect like oneself but it's
also
a opposition or antithesis to the
universal and he uses two different
words there alga mina alga mine heights
right i don't think we have to worry too
much about the the distinction
there i don't think hegel's trying to
make any any point with the shift in
terminology but what is important here
is that this universal is what was
supposed to bring together
the individual and all the other
individuals
the other self-consciousnesses right so
now we have an opposition
where there's a movement against a
pushing away
a disjunction you know the gagan and the
gagan's us
right and so he goes on the this
antithesis
inevitably comes on the scene and we
have to consider this relationship
and its movement in other words
this universality and duty
so duty is on this side have the very
opposite significance of the specific
individuality that exempts itself from
the
universality and here
he's going to be you know talking he's
going to be using different different
terms that
we'll get to in a moment so
it exempts itself from the universal how
does it exempt itself well
pure duty is only a universality that
appears on the surface
it's superficial and is turned outward
duty here's an interesting
thing to say is only a matter of words
and counts
as a being for another so
only a matter of words like well
of course it is only a matter of words
it lies in language
in you know spracha or reida and the
thing that allowed us
to hit this medium that allowed us to
have the universal to see ourselves in
the universal to be
with other people and recognized
now that's no longer the case
so the individual here
acting is going to reject
this being for another
that was attained in there is that a
good thing is that a bad thing well that
remains to be seen
so he says conscience which in the first
instance is only negatively directed
against duty
as this given specific duty so there's
an earlier stage where
i have to act i have to particularize
the duty that i'm engaged in and again
we saw this this work itself out
many times in the morality section we
saw this in
other parts of spirit we saw this in
other parts of reason
right where we're considering moral
duties
duty per se is a kind of
bloodless abstract conception my actual
duties that i have
when i try to do them seem to like come
out against
duty per se or against other specific
duties that other specific individuals
might have
and now he says we go beyond this only
negative
he says how so we know ourselves are
we know ourselves to be free from duty
as
such how how do we do that
we feel the empty conception of duty the
empty duty he's calling it here but the
empty
notion of of duty with a specific
content
where we're getting this content from
from ourselves
it's not simply imposed on us from on
high
or told us by you know the people we've
internalized as whatever you want to
call it you know
uh something like the freudian superego
these these voices nattering in our head
be a good boy be a good girl do this do
that right
no it's not coming from anything like
that this is gavison this is conscience
and the conscientious individual says i
can act on my own i can
give myself duties i can recognize that
and it's going to come
out of my own perspective where i happen
to be
i don't have to wait around for somebody
to tell me what to do i can figure it
out
and thereby act so
he goes on here and this is where we get
some of these these other
qualifiers he says it's
positively aware that it as this
particular self makes the content
in its pure self is an empty knowing is
devoid of content and determination so
it's leaving that behind that's over
here on this side
with the universal and the other
individualities the content which it
gives
to that knowing is taken from its own
self
as this specific self and then here he
goes on
is taken from itself as a natural
individuality and here he uses the word
individuality
not einstein heights is there a
significance
there well maybe to some degree the
individuality that is natural
is you know the the very body that i
have the drives the desires
that i have the inclinations that i have
the specificity
of of me and we could say it also
extends to
our spatial location and
our place in not just time
but in narratives and history and
within social structures all of these
things that what makes me
not just me is an individuality but
makes me
as the person i am within a
social matrix all of that
is where i'm getting my content from for
my my action
and not just for my action but also as
we're going to see well
let's go on a little bit further so he
says uh
in speaking of the conscientiousness
of its action it may well be aware of
its pure self but in the purpose
of its action a purpose with an actual
content it is aware of itself as this
particular
individual right so
we have you know content for knowing
knowing what i'm going to do knowing
what i should do knowing why i'm
justifying it
as what i had to do but the purpose
the point the goal the intentionality of
it
belongs to me and it's coming out of me
i become aware of myself as this
particular individual
conscious of the antithesis be between
what it is for itself
how it relates itself to itself and what
it is for others and
and in some respects you could say it
either it doesn't care about what it is
for others
or says what it is for others doesn't
really matter in terms of its own
intentionality
or perhaps it even just goes against it
deliberately
right maybe there is that gagan against
in there
an opposition so that here he then
closes by saying the antithesis of
universality or duty
right what's over here on this side and
its reflection out of universality into
itself so now we have
you know fuller understanding of what
this reflection into itself consists of
it means looking at its own
life situation mentality and getting
positive content for what it's going to
do is enacting
consciousness acting in accordance with
conscience
from that
while in this way the antithesis into
which conscience enters when it
acts expresses itself in its inner being
the antithesis
is at the same time a disparity on its
outer side in the element of existence
the disparity of its particular
individuality in relation to another
individual
its particularity consists in the fact
that the two moments constituting its
consciousness
the self and the in itself are held to
be unequal in value within
it a disparity in which they are so
determined that the certainty of itself
is the essential being
in face of the in itself or the
universal which counts only as
a moment in contrast to this
internal determination there thus stands
the element of existence or
universal consciousness for which the
essential being
is rather universality duty well
individuality on the other hand which is
in contrast to the universal is for
itself
counts only as a superseded moment for
the consciousness which holds firmly to
duty the first consciousness counts as
evil
because of the disparity between its
inner being and the universal and sense
at the same time
this first consciousness declares its
action to be in conformity with itself
to be duty and conscientiousness it is
held by the universal consciousness to
be
hypocrisy
paragraph 660 also deals with the acting
consciousness or
acting conscience the gavison
that engages in intentional action
action that could be repeated action
that could be
in some way justified not a mere
act taught but rather handled
comportment behavior and
it's going to be shifting focus now
to looking at how other consciousnesses
look at this you know rather
self-contained self-sufficient
self-justifying conscience that
is engaging in action
and the way that it's ultimately going
to frame this is in terms of
evil and hypocrisy so how do we get
there
so he tells us while in this way the
antithesis
into which conscience enters when it
acts
expresses itself in its inner
being right so let's let's pause on that
this
opposition or antithesis gagan zots
into which conscience enters when it
acts so in the previous paragraph we
you know explored this it has to do
something it has to take some
particular concrete stand
some sort of choice decision
doing something attempting something at
least it might not actually be
successful
in what it does but there is some
particularization
and this arises not just it as a
negative
opposition to a universal duty
but as drawing positive content out of
itself
and its own motivational structure its
purposes right so
this happens on the part of acting
conscious
consciousness and conscience and
there is something being expressed in
its inner being within
itself you could say within its
consciousness in in that
domain and so then he says the
antithesis
is at the same time something external
it's a disparity
on its outer side in the element
of existence you use the word elementa
there
the element of dozen of
you know being true existing
viewer clique acting you know actual
beings so we have not just an individual
who has a certain conflict within
themselves or some sort of unreconciled
contradiction you could say but there's
also
something going on in relation to other
individualities
and we saw this in the previous
paragraph right there is an opposition
not just to universal but to
other individualities now the other
individuality
speaking in place of the universal gets
to say some things back
to this consciousness and so disparity
and glychite they're not equal to each
other
there's some sort of discrepancy a
discordance between them
and he says its particularity
now we're coming back to the first
consciousness consists in the fact
that the two moments constituting its
consciousness the self
and the in itself are held to be unequal
in value
within it so there's a there's a
disparity or
you know unequalness you know maybe even
an uncomparative ability
within the two as well so there's a
inner expression of this contradiction
between the in itself the on
zeke right and the self
and so we could say is this between the
in itself and the four
itself yes but but hegel doesn't talk
about that here he just says
the self and what is the on z
in itself it's the universal that it has
it you know along with everybody else
sort of implanted within itself
and then it has its own inner being as
an acting
subject and it prioritizes the
inner being it says i don't have to
actually go by the universal
i've got what i need in myself to make
the right decisions to do the right
things
to you know go back to this
this conception of knowing willing
acting
speaking it can do all of those on its
own
so he says that uh they're held to be
unequal
it's a disparity in which they're so
determined
that the certainty of itself so here's
very something very important right we
should dwell on this for a bit
conscience in this entire section is
supposed to be
certain of itself right so that's
important for our conscience organism
attaining certainty is also something
absolutely important within the hegelian
dialectic we have this constant
interplay
between certainty and truth
and you start out generally from the
position of certainty
you think you know something you're very
confident about something
and then you see how it plays itself out
and when you attain
the truth of it the certainty has been
diminished weakened left behind
and a new certainty has to be
established is that what we're doing
here is that is that what we've
achieved finally at this point
in conscience well to a certain degree
yes looking looking ahead right
so the certainty is lying on the side of
the self not on the side
of the universal and so the certainty of
itself
he says is the essential being
in face of the in itself or the
universal which counts only as
a moment right it it it
matters only in relation to what is
giving it
you might say a place to live rent free
in its head right
the way that we talk about these things
today
the universal is granted a kind of
space or validity
only in so far as it's related here to
to the
the self which means that if it goes
against what the self has decided to do
so much the worse for the universal
right too bad
uh we leave the universal behind or
perhaps we
keep it along with us but um
we're kind of stuck with it now that's
what's going on inside
and being translated into an externality
which now stands against other
externalities
who represent the universal
and he says here here we go
in contrast to this internal
determination there thus stands the
element of existence
and what is this element of existence
universal consciousness
everybody else the rest of society or at
least
you know some people who present
themselves
as those who get to speak on behalf of
the universal and this could be
you know quite sociologically
conditioned it might be
a certain class it might be uh
you know people who have you know made
themselves the center and leaders
of this it might be certain other
people think about the role of you know
priests or bards
in in societies where they didn't rule
but actually had a considerable amount
of let's call it cultural capital right
so it doesn't necessarily have to be
every single you know person in society
is against this other individuality
as a matter of fact it could even be the
amorphous they
that we encounter in heidegger or
you know in other places this this
notion of there being this kind of
amorphous public opinion or
[Music]
average everyday consciousness whatever
we want to call it but
you know now it gets to have a say so
he tells us that um
here we go in contrast this this
internal determination there's the
element of existence or universal
consciousness how does that look at
the essential being is rather
universality
duty now notice how hegel phrased that
there so universal consciousness
what is essential for it the universal
it's kind of engaging in the same
self-assertion is it not
this often gets overlooked as
the individual is engaging in
self-assertion
sort of like conscience writ large and
it consolidates
you know what's essential into this
notion of duty obligation flicked
what is required moral norm we could say
but as we've seen this is this is a
rather abstract
conception of duty as soon as we start
to translate it into anything we run
into
all sorts of antinomies so he goes on
and he says
here we go
[Music]
individuality on the other hand which in
contrast to the universal
is for itself is counted only as a
superseded moment so
from the perspective of the
universal and the individuals who
represent or embody or are captivated by
the universal
this individuality is supposed to be
superseded alcoholban right
it's supposed to you know orient itself
actually let's let's talk about another
term that we often use to translate
alpha haben right sublation it should be
carried under the universal
that's that's the way that the universal
looks at it so how then is it going to
regard the universal's
self-assertion and de-prioritization of
the universal
within itself it's claiming to
listen to the voice of conscience but
the voice of conscience is not the
universal
in itself it is the self asserting
itself
so he goes on and he says for the
consciousness which holds firmly to duty
the consciousness
that you know looks at things through
the eyes of the universal
the first consciousness counts as evil
why now this is where it gets kind of
interesting
it's not evil just because
well you're transgressing this moral
norm which has been established by the
universal consciousness
and you're behaving badly in an external
way
that is evil in one sense but that's not
what hegel says here
he says it's evil because it doesn't
recognize or doesn't it does
recognize but doesn't give the right
value to
the in itself within it the
universal that all of us share in right
so you you don't listen to proper
conscience you listen to your own
screwed up conscience which isn't even
really conscience
from the perspective of the universal
and so that's what makes it
evil in this case and now
the the other consciousness the first
consciousness gets to respond and say
i am actually doing what i'm supposed to
do i'm following
conscience i am you know going through
this entire
development of action particularization
intention and so he says the first
consciousness declares its action to be
in conformity
with itself now notice he goes a little
bit further to be duty
and conscientiousness and so the
universal consciousness gets the last
word here and says
you're not just evil you're actually a
hypocrite
you are putting on heirs you
are misappropriating the very
language and concepts so that you can
make yourself
feel good about your evil intention
or mindset and individual
behavior going against the moral norm
you're actually trying to assume the
mantle
of duty against duty
so you're a hypocrite evil and a
hypocrite that's how
the acting consciousness is going to be
identified by other acting
consciousnesses
who in a certain respect are less
developed
at this point than the person
who is conscientious
you